787.5 millones de dólares es la cifra
que la cadena de televisión Fox news
deberá pagar a dominio por insistems
como parte de una cuerda alcanzado en la
corte entre las partes evitando un
juicio por difamación de alto nivel la
compañía de máquinas que hacen recuentos
de votos en las elecciones de Estados
Unidos acusó a Fox de difundir
deliberadamente información falsa sobre
el supuesto rol de sus productos en los
resultados de las elecciones de 2020 en
las que Donald Trump resultó perdedor
llegaron a un acuerdo histórico Fox
admitió haber dicho mentiras sobre el
dominio que causó un daño enorme a mi
empresa a nuestros empleados y a los
clientes a los que servimos nada podrá
compensar eso a lo largo de este proceso
hemos buscado responsabilidad y creo que
la evidencia Sacada a la luz a través de
este caso subraya las consecuencias de
difundir mentiras los presentadores más
reconocidos de la cadena que dieron
amplia cobertura a los infundados
señalamientos de fraude no están
obligados a reconocer al aire las
mentiras pronunciadas la suma acordada
es algo menos de la mitad de la que
solicitaba inicialmente dominion que
demandó por 1600 millones de dólares
mediante un comunicado Fox reaccionó al
acuerdo asegurando que la compañía está
comprometida con mantener los más altos
estándares periodísticos
la verdad no conoce el rojo o el azul
las personas de todo el espectro
político pueden estar en desacuerdos
sobre algunos temas pero para que
nuestra democracia dure otros 250 años
debemos compartir un compromiso con los
hechos tras resolver este caso el canal
se enfrenta a otra demanda impuesta por
la empresa de sistemas para elecciones
Smart matic que le reclama 2700 millones
de dólares por haberla involucrado
también en este desmentido fraude
electoral